I have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine two david p have been
getting a lot of voicemails about andrew
yang 20/20 democratic candidate and his
universal basic income plan here's one
from a caller who is skeptical about it
take a listen
hi David this is Brendan I just wanted
to call in and talk to you about a
Andrew yang in his $1,000 a month policy
I'm just little skeptical of that you
know I think that instead of giving out
free money to people and allowing them
to do whatever they want with it we
should be using it for more social
services in like welfare and you know
stuff like that programs that could help
people and I don't think just giving
away money is gonna I think it's like a
scapegoat basically you know like oh
here's a few extra dollars don't don't
worry about all the other stuff that's
wrong yeah I don't think so ok this is
there's elements of a fair critique
there and there's elements that are not
accurate I believe it is true that there
is a problem if you are replacing
welfare programs with universal basic
income because as I told Andrew yang if
you replace a thousand and welfare
benefits with a thousand in just general
money you're not really raising people's
standard of living his argument is that
you're distinct that thousand dollars
that if you get a thousand dollars from
food stamps and other programs that
there's stigma associated with that
there's means-testing there's a
bureaucracy if you give people the money
free and clear you're better enabling
them to just do what they want to do
people who may be deliberately don't
work because they believe that they are
going to lose benefits to some degree if
they start working and they want to hide
what they're doing from the government
there is an element of that that is that
is completely true but my real concern
is not the problem of just giving people
free money I don't actually don't think
that's a problem and we've addressed
address that many times my concern is
that there are ways to do ubi
that will not cause a cost of living to
increase in proportion with that ubi and
there are ways that will cause a cost of
living to increase at least somewhat in
proportion with that and we've delved
into that in detail and I encourage
to check out my videos on it but you're
sort of like half right with your
critique and missing some elements of it
we will talk much more about ubi for
sure we've got a great bonus show for
you today become a member become a
patron to get instant access that's it
for today